あ
ん
こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん
ダーツしますあっはぁまぁじゃあちょっとで聞くとなんかこう
夜の遊びみたいな雰囲気があるんですがダンスは誰でも楽しめる簡単なゲームダーツが
できるものさえあればどこでも誰でもパーツが楽しむことができます
ダンズって歓談クリアを準備しマントに向かってあげるだけ投げてほしいよって得点が
変わってチェーンを競ったり
一つのフージュン向かったりルールはさまさまさそんな楽しいダーツゲームなんです
けども僕はあることに気付いてしまいました
ご覧ください
ダーツの的ってめちゃくちゃなだけじゃねー私は来てしまいました
ダウンの家
どかぎさせるとかなってと言ってここにできるだけだつの家を集めてみました
ダーツするお店ようにたくさんあると思いますあの
見たことないんですよ何ってこう3つくらい投げて抜いて次の人はまたやるんね大2の
的にたくさん矢が刺さったの方見たことないんですよ
逆になぜサーブを抜くのかなとここ思いましてダンスの家がたくさんあったら別に抜く
必要がないんじゃねーか抜く時間がもったいないと思ってラージのや抜かなかったら
どんなことが起きるの可能性&ダーツの的はどんな感じになるのかっていうのは
ちょっとスレタイので
今日はダンスの的が限界になるまで立つを投げてみようと思いますわかんないちょっと
考えられるパターンとしては重さねもう的がどうすると落ちるかそれがを投げても投げ
てもや傘さんな色の穴が入るスペースがなくなるか他の何かが起きるかちょっと色んな
事が判明いられるんですけどもな権利だから
篠山かるた部的がお花みたいな感じになると思うんでしょどうなるかわかんないっても
やってみ
ん
温度するだけしてはねぼくやってみたいだけなんですかもよこれぞ
不屈ははじめ最強ぴーぼー
[音楽]
ハオ系バルガー se 4
うん
をダウンだうッッ
おっ
ポンッ
4水への取り組みだ20というえんがいし限界しっこ
以後れ審議したんです結構2重取りですよね
ランダースティーク敗目うんすごいよ
は4わー for peace 4 s ううっうぅううレイヤー様へ
っていうことにブルーいやーよ事項て抹茶
4 t 5 ae ああはいどーこう
矢部8くるようになってきた早くもいないかもしれないんだこれと同
こんっ
マジでっ
グループはカンナ全然合って免停ですよね大向う
をいっぱい
恥かねぇもう転生とか良いプレゼンいっぱいしますガー
待ってください高
ブーバー死刑ワッペン処方ジャン
はぁ
でああ
ん
わーわー
per
ウォン ana ああっああんああーっ
[拍手]
ブーバーしポンッ
ブーブーエロ
あっはぁんっ
cesar
[音楽]
me
kuh
rar
me
バッハ
はあああああ
うわぁすげぇ分ウォッチ2
すごいおっさんダーツで立ちます